On the subject of sizing,
there are some CSS units
that you may not have heard of, but
which are now really widely supported.
How about if you want an image
to responsively cover the whole
height of the viewport?
Now, you can always do that by setting
the height of the image to 100%.
But that only works if
the height of the HTML and
the body elements are also set to 100%.
A simple way is to use the VH unit,
which stands for viewport height.
One VH unit corresponds to
1% of the viewport height,
and so 100 VH means 100% height.
You can do the same with VW for
viewport width.
Here you can see we've set
the width of the image to be 100vw,
100% of the viewport width.
And you can see that it
resizes responsibly.
Another common responsive use case is
when you want an image to resize to
fit the smaller of the height or
the width of the viewport.
The vmin unit, viewport minimum,
corresponds to 1% of the viewport
width or height, whichever is smaller.
If you set both the width and
the height to 100vmin,
you'll get the effect you're after.
How about if you want an image
to cover the whole viewport but
without stretching or squashing?
For this you can use the vmax unit,
which corresponds to 1% of the viewport
width or height, whichever is greater.
So, if you set both the height and
the width to 100vmax,
the image responsively resizes
to cover the viewport.